et on vous en parlait il ya quelques
minutes
juan gouaille d'eau en quête de soutiens
après la colombie bruxelles londres ou
encore davos il poursuit sa tournée
internationale
il est reçu cet après midi par emmanuel
macron au palais de l'elysée et pour en
parler nous recevons sur ce plateau
stéphane witkowski ch merci d'être avec
nous en direct sur rt france je rappelle
que vous êtes président du conseil
d'orientation stratégique de l'institut
des hautes études d'amérique dont joue
rebonjour à merci d'être avec nous en
direct sur rt france alors que peut
espérer le roi ngaido de sa rencontre
avec emmanuel macron qui a lieu d'ici
quelques minutes
il vient chercher une légitimité à
l'étranger il n'a jamais eu dans son
pays
donc c'est une erreur diplomatique de la
france de le recevoir une faute
politique une erreur une erreur
diplomatique parce que la france a une
tradition les reconnaître les états et
non pas du gouvernement et encore moins
de président de problèmes et que d'autre
part la france la diplomatie s'appuie
sur les règles de droit international
public et la communauté internationale
elle s'exprime par l'intermédiaire de
l'onu et l'onu n'a jamais reconnu aussi
bordeaux et qu'en plus la diplomatie
française n'a pas de tradition de
s'aligner sur la politique
nord-américaine et en particulier
l'administration trump dont la sphère
vénézuélienne
comment comprendre ce déplacement de
juan garrido font aujourd'hui il est en
quête de soutien de pays étrangers
notamment de pays européens une thèse de
certains pays européens certes mais pas
toute la communauté vignes européenne
bien évidemment soutient la fois
politique et financier les états unis
mais en fait il est en perte de vitesse
depuis plus d'un an puisque ça fait
maintenant un an s'est autoproclamé
président du venezuela qu'il n'a pas été
réélu contrairement à ce qu'on dit
il n'a pas été réélu président de
l'assemblée nationale 5 janvier 2020 et
donc il est en perte de vitesse dans son
propre pays et il est à la recherche en
effet d'appuis extérieurs pour
poursuivre son combat d'onde sur la
scène médiatique angers en grande partie
depuis un an qu'elle a été la position
diplomatique d'emmanuel m'apprend
justement sur ce sujet après que juan
garrido s'est autoproclamé président du
venezuela
ça a été effectivement de reconnaître
monsieur guido après je dirais un tweet
de lune pendant huit jours président
maduro d'organiser des élections
évidemment au bout de dix jours le
résultat a été clair la tradition de la
france a toujours été jusqu'à lors de
respecter à la fois l'indépendance
nationale la souveraineté nationale des
peuples de non-ingérence dans les
affaires intérieures et cette tradition
a toujours été maintenus du général de
gaulle jusqu'à l'avènement du président
un maquereau est en fait que ce soit les
gouvernements de droite ou de gauche
c'est une tradition nationale française
vis-à-vis de la région qu'en est-il sur
place dans la rue aujourd'hui les
vénézuéliens quelle image ils ont de
roanne gouaille des os que la population
et des est divisée sur son statut en
terme de popularité selon les sondages
son image beaucoup beaucoup dégradée
d'une part parce qu'il avait promis
beaucoup de choses il avait d'abord
annoncé sur deux articles de la
constitution le 23 janvier l'année
dernière qu'il organisera des élections
dans deux de moi ça n'a pas été fait
ensuite il ya eu un certain nombre
d'annoncés annonçant la fin du régime
intervention humanitaire en février
avec le pont avec la colombie le
venezuela tentative de soulèvement
militaire au mois d'avril qui a été un
échec
un certain nombre d'affaires de de
corruption dans lequel il était impliqué
avec des financements aussi tiers pays
tiers il a été vu avec des narcos et
paramilitaires colombiens dans un
certain nombre de situations donc son
image est très dégradé et non seulement
elle est dégradée dans le pays
mais en même temps l'opposition est
profondément divisé parce que
l'assemblée nationale actuelle elle est
entre les mains de l'opposition
et c'est parce qu'il savait qu'il ne
serait pas réélu président de
l'assemblée nationale parce qu'une
grande partie d'opposition elle contre
lui il n'a pas souhaité se représenter
de manière classique c'est-à-dire
d'entrer dans l'hémicycle pour pouvoir
briguer pour se passer la raison pour
laquelle il a laissé autoproclamé une
seconde fois président de l'assemblée
nationale or toute norme
constitutionnelle le vénézuélienne en
souviens c'était le 7 janvier un saut ou
le retour à l'assemblée nationale de
juan garrido entourée de nombreuses
caméras nombreux journalistes
comment est-ce que roy noyau est perçue
par les médias n'en pays
les médias nationaux vous savez les
médias nationaux sont très son trait
c'est une situation très polarisée au
venezuela il ya beaucoup de de presse
d'opposition aussi qu'ils sont très
virulents dont il ya les pour et les
contre à l'étranger il sait très
utilement utilisé je dirais son image
avec la télévision les appuis des
grandes médias internationaux et donc il
sait très bien joué de sa de de la
presse internationale mais cette ces
images sons sont
exclusivement à destination de politique
étrangère en particulier mais dans le
pays eut même sateco est de plus en plus
faible dans le payer par conséquent ce
la raison pour laquelle il est en
cherche en recherche de légitimité à
l'étranger et l'armée dont on connaît à
la place stratégique dans le pays elle
n'entend pas non plus et appelle
aujourd'hui
non parce que effectivement il ya
toujours cette unité ces unités civiques
aux militaires dans le pays et il a
pensé que l'armée allait se disent aussi
à plusieurs reprises il a fait des
appels à l'insurrection de l'armée pour
renverser manado l'onu nicholas monroe
est en réalité l'armée est totalement
fidèles au régime du président m'a
d'euros et donc toutes les annonces qui
ont été faites depuis plus d'un an le
bilan de sa présidence autoproclamé au
goût de noix elle est absolument presque
à néant nul dans ce contexte là pour
conclure la position des états unis du
coup un an après cette autoproclamation
souvient les états unis qui avait été
l'un des premiers pays à reconnaître
bien entendu parce que évidemment comme
on est dans une année électorale pour
donald trump il a besoin toujours
de mettre tous les faire affaire et
notamment de cultiver cette communauté
latino-américaine aux états unis il va
probablement pas faire de geste
particulier
vis-à-vis de 2 2 2
en vis-à-vis du venezuela mais en tout
cas il va probablement maintenir cette
ligne jusqu'à l'élection présidentielle
américaine
mais ils se rendent bien compte aussi
notamment parmi les conseillers de trump
que ils ont vous avez misé sur le entre
guillemets le mauvais cheval
merci beaucoup et stéphane witkowski
d'avoir accepté notre invitation des
règles sur rt frange rappel vous êtes
président du conseil d'orientation
stratégique à l'institut des hautes
études de l'amérique latine
merci beaucoup